[Music]
every our steps agreed for benching
insulin sneaky and also Shh foolish step
up for the six men
the findings are spot so in June 2018
five nine shocked League of Legends fans
by announcing that Jensen sneaky and
smoothy
we're gonna be riding the bench while
being replaced by their corresponding
academy players going for the Academy
team and your if your goal is to be on
the cloud NLCS team you would prove it
by being professional working hard
working our teammates
[Music]
ultimately you know reapered hold me and
the coaches step aside and said hey
listen like this team is not gonna make
playoffs and what do you what do you
want the to do jack do you want me to do
the moves that are necessary to make
this a winning team and tell them hey
this I'll follow your lead if you want
to make these changes I back you up a
percent
better 10th place to world after winning
the NA LCS 2014 spring finals cloud9 has
never been able to place higher than
second in the postseason since then team
solomid has had their number
[Applause]
Naxos Falls and team solomid are the
2015 North American League of Legends
Championship Series spring split
champions as TSM submit themselves as
the most dominant organization North
American League of Legends and win their
fourth
ts never gonna
[Applause]
but once again
[Applause]
meanwhile how nine star players were
getting unmotivated according to
statements interviews and even a video
cloud nine put out themselves
Jennsen smoothie and sneaky just weren't
performing as well in scrims as their
corresponding academy players throughout
the course of our pre-season efforts it
really showed that these Academy players
were putting in a ton of effort and
playing very well as it seemed together
and we wanted to put together the best
possible team for our week one stage so
the team benched them pretty I guess
unreal because it's Jensen and sneaky
like they're kind of it's unheard of for
those kind of players to be benched so
it's like pretty crazy to me but I was
really excited because I just I've been
working really hard I'm really excited
for the opportunity
so Cod 9 entered the season with a
roster mostly made up of Academy players
while their all-stars dumped on younger
players in the Academy faces kills
coming through sneakiest lunch in there
with nine killed before the season
started no one can understand cloud 9
decision to bench those three players
but behind the scenes there was a sea
change reapered saw three star players
underperforming and didn't hesitate to
bench them giving their spots to more
motivated Academy players and they did
all of this no fear that they would lose
their spawn the league if it didn't work
out we are trying to best for win today
even no one trusts you guys I'm trusting
your eyes
that's totally mirror yeah right all
right
three ounces I mean one two three
by week five cloud nine was three and
seven while cloud nine Academy was 11 in
one so they brought back Jensen and
sneaky and literally tried out smoothie
hazel was actually more successful then
they're placed fence Karen with blabber
and that's when things really fell into
place being chased down this could be
very very big can they burn out to flash
away and a sleepy Brahma put up the
shield of walk backward stays alive now
are we engaged chemistry like it's
Lanza plate comes down look at the
damage though because they pick a mob
Stephen gets one will it be a trade not
just yet he cuts away seems alive in a
tosser to his nose because old health
induces here
if that kills Abel stays up on this one
cloud9 to pedir in the fight making a
furnace Jensen finds the other Danish
member to check how nine started to win
game and they were just winning they
were rushing there about looking for the
big play in the front line looking for
the knock him down I'm gonna find the
target to kill Jensen is godlike with
the death cap explosion look at the
backlight hot close drop to brother
Bali's already God the first revive
coming through no kills in the board yet
for clutch and the backside act is not
gonna happen if Evans plane cannot get
it to go through um for Brazil and so
it's gonna be the spit
Vic tells come fast and furious a triple
for Jin and that is the base going down
they can say for the turret Hopkins
holds the people into the bot Lane this
is certainly going to be the game
clabber the new jungler is a much more
aggressive player that's been scary he's
always bitching for a kill and that
means his team has the ball
it's santora's looking to make the play
on to Jensen who tries to get himself
away now looking to maybe turn things
back around blabber looking to go deep
find the killer Kane when blabber went
ahead and flashed in and you guys were
working together was it instinct was a
coordination or what I had no idea said
johnny was going to be down he was
around mid so I think we're just two
really aggressive players and then
that's kind of just how I went down at
least yeah Bubba really likes killing
people but that doesn't mean Spence
Caron can't hold his own he showed up
again in week 8 alongside along the line
to meet a later golden glow in a match
against Team Liquid the first place team
at the time just when you think cloud 9
hasn't figured out they go ahead and do
something crazy like switching up their
roster again yeah so golden glue and
Spence Caron are in and River had this
to say he's basically saying Jensen
blabbering golden who's fen have been
practicing as pairs and you can't
explain fully obviously but he's saying
they prepared for this and is strategic
to win against Team Liquid and they want
the ability to swap between those jewels
and playoffs since you can have seven in
the playoffs and with all that being
said I hate the fact that they're doing
this the last time they played Team
Liquid they won with blabber and Jensen
you have to trust your guys that are hot
I feel like cloud nine is outsmarting
themselves and the potential for this to
blow up is so high that
if they win against humility I still
don't like that there's seven these guys
out for this game
no one soft pile of nines roster moved
Kali golden blue and Spence karen has
been practicing together and while
golden glue is on paper not as good a
middling or as Jensen their synergy
convinced e9 just some of them in and as
a duo and it worked then coach trying to
wrap around if he goes for a flash Q and
hits it you will get the kill a phone
call to heal Olli Lance acute just
straight up clean no spinning Tibbets
bed we gonna fight or no grandpa what
and now maybe you just gonna stop the
fight animate these big mistake
proposals are dice play from spent his
fence caring again the arrows well gonna
try lady missile because of when the cue
the watch is craving for Bella but I
think that's his dad we're about the
dust go down to spend golden blue still
so strong stuns Pavelka Jews gonna land
bet the old town and that should be a
kill fence Garen on a rampage for zero
and zero cents
Garen links so so well this he's
impotent no offense here maybe take him
down before we can all save the c9 steal
the Drake away as well on the potential
play la is gonna be the first target
down double it golden blue just a rate
this team as X we be kicked out of the
respite dies as well
that's the turns gonna die actually all
my football at the same time in fact
idiots on the front that sends care of
tries to make it happen but he's gonna
dance out the TA still got pumped it
impact he's gonna be looks to fall down
sneaky I'm gonna get on the Nexus open
at nine with another fluff smash
teamliquid absolutely destroy them in
its golden glue and spend scare and the
subs coming in performing so incredibly
well
cloud9 went from three and seven in week
5 to 11 and seven in week 9 earning a
bind to the playoff semifinals improving
every one thing and the damage on the
Santorin is enough to kill him on the
step to the fountain cloud 9 what an
incredible showing here up against fly
quest
they'll take the Nexus they'll take the
BAI and they are taking the a else
and once they were in playoff they were
able to show exactly why their strategy
worked the fall season at least for a
little while
TSM and c9 traded games back and forth
for the first three games of the series
with TSM going up to two Wow the turrets
are falling rapidly it is still 15 to 20
seconds of most of doing back he finally
fights but it's too late he's alone
against four
there's no minions wetness alt doesn't
matter and TSM aura came away from the
finals it looked like PSM had the upper
hand like cloud 9 was running out of
steam it looked like it always had but
TSM was going to win until cloud 9
pulled out their trump card welcome to
game 4 TSM with side selection picked
red side and cloud 9 have switched a
round of their roster golden glue and
spent scaring her in cloud 9 brought in
Spence Caron and golden key to put some
fire back into c9 and finally get the
rest of the way to beat TSM it's it's a
bold move but you okay like they said on
that desk if you're gonna run this 7 man
roster you're already down two games
it's the time you have to do it this
could be a fight now in the mid lane not
gonna be routed in place just yet but
now hurry again towards the bottom slice
and EP being shot up basil trying to run
through to your life that flows in a
sneaky and aware can cloud9 go as hot
sir tepees
she'll have spent scary Kosovo teammate
the sneak he's going to fall be
resurrected but still the reengage a
huge show that a hunter looking for more
as he looks at the dig now going to
clues days look at the trade though but
it's still to four to the bottom side
both kills going to misty not ideal
yes I'm gonna find Gordon blue shirts
not gonna lend us yet now the Oaks going
in the stuns a lot of damage if he could
be falling for this one and they will
kill him up a shutdown and look at the
knock ups a double flash out of TSM
getting away from that call as licorice
tea feet in that might be the kind of
fights they want a knock upon answer is
this the target down to a thousand and
the olds coming across to his authority
burned and they've passed trundle and I
was already dead it's one four zero the
Oaks cut across great getting love
addiction kids found em but Spence cares
get aboard to be revived giant not for
the backline the bombs not but he's done
toast at CSM still on the run
can they start methi and they will
zero cloud nine five feet or inside the
base hope that make it she came by the
flash hot early fans would put the flash
card and here to get the kill the trade
back though the huge can then secure the
hey Clark I will double killer stinky
Tehran falling now TSM are routed there
inside their face the Nexus
bring out the silver scripts we're going
to game fine
I gave him what if story yes sirree this
song's coming in time this is insane who
wrote this script to say I never saw
this copy before give an array insane
when the summer split started no one
understood what cloud that it was doing
and to be fair to the doubters from the
outside looking in those first few weeks
did seem terrible but cloud 9 we're just
letting a fire under their star players
they were showings at a deep bench and a
commitment to bringing in your subs is
another way to win they will do battle
with TSM one final time today the
determine who will be in the finals to
the ultimate defeat and Poppy's far away
they're both gonna keep in a joint here
comes up fight 5 B 5 is this the one
that ends it all great getting away
burning down trying to stay alive two
four zero cloud time
[Applause]
for stinky
if they get the game I think
the subs make it a cheese here at a
close-up the series a very small wave
instead of the Nexus to practice of a
separate
smithy must've been against outside
that's the second Jared falls the
responses
they've done it shouldn't scary to go to
glue completed it's the great job extra
time
[Applause]
has been completed place to the finals
in summer of 2018
thanks their deep bench and commitment
to bringing in their other mid jungle
duo cloud 9 brought down TSM in the
playoffs for the first time in four
years all that was left was finals
welcome back to the Oracle Arena it is
time for the finals of the North
American LCS 2018 summer split by an
despite their impressive performance in
the semi finals how do I got absolutely
obliterated in the finals but that's
this open there is no defense since
Garrett shows up but the base will fall
back-to-back sweeps
Daymond North America 302 teamliquid
meaning they only had one shot left at
making the world's winning the gauntlet
fight
Paulo battle arena and hello Internet it
is time almost for Game one of the
regional qualifier finals thanks their
second place finish in the playoffs
cloud9 receded automatically into the
gauntlet findings and their opponents
were once again yes such big stakes for
this match the last spot for North
America at World the coveted spot here
up for grabs between TSM and cloud nine
but cloud nine had a plan somehow
liquorice had figured out that hecarim
was a counter to aatrox a champion that
c9 had identified was really important
to TSM well ever since hecarim got buffs
and people started playing it in Jungle
again I was trying to make it work in
top lane and we had some pretty bad
results beside before and then yesterday
we saw that TSM had like really high
aatrox priority so like last night I was
like hey I wonder if this is a good
matchup so I tried it in a couple
everyone's and it was a good match other
they nabbed at each Hawks for themselves
when Game one of the series and put him
on top of TSM cloud9 let's go with this
a talk yeah then how nine brought in
hecarim to take down monsters of a
trough
it's hecarim table over and over again
v1 on to Greg pushing him back as look
for some damage here a lot of pain out
half these people come to the plastic
ball
died and now a few on top side haunts
are cutting away Jensen here is where
we'll be plaster fall yes
the wind comes in there's the
OpenDocument pull the acro and down
comes galleon gonna go to wanaka but
he's feared he does not have anything
but the flash and it won't matter Jessup
except that killed five two three cloud
nine and the long-range against and as
they go for a fee to go to the mid lane
blanche comes through two kills on the
bottom leaner and the TP is her
liquorice he has the oldsman he's gonna
go in he's gonna find the beer here
comes the thighs they'll pick up his
knee and now watch her might have been
up for the deikun shoe doesn't find the
pullback
it's a five III he's still tied with the
old fish
and it is gonna be a cleaning series as
well two games in their heads triple
match point in cloud nine could be the
team that prevents TSM forever
this year one more to go cloud9 to zero
okay here comes the fight whatever
whatever let's fight as well can be
picked up on the red side but licorice
get the kill on a Greg and now they're
going for two should be able to get it
these that have you're never coming and
this could be the team fight they're
gonna get Craig and his cute aside cool
down
no flashy either no way out one picked
up that was nicely done
Bobby's gonna flash away silly but that
first killed it was hot so comes in as
well
bactrim they're gonna find the fear get
the kill on his man here to watch
another one he's gonna get blabbered one
but he can't find it he was executing
for the target liquorice behind them
already
the offers been flashing away with this
together fear of the creek getting the
chase down sooner and yes they do down
to just be written watching his kingdom
follow the ashes as cloud 9 will knock
down the face de wallen bomb here's a
lot on this side
guess what's wrong
300
to finals is a great story better 10th
place to world
cloud9 came out on top beating TSM with
yet another strange offbeat strategy
that ended up paying dividends leaving
their rivals in the dust and punching
their ticket to Worlds c9 with an
incredible run this year coach of the
split had the faith in the right players
and a 3o sweep at the end of the
regional qualifier six worlds in a row
for c9 sneaky congratulations on the win
from 10th to Worlds what's going through
your head right now um feel pretty good
even though he lost finals it was pretty
bad we were able to come back and
realize a pretty good amount of our
problems and I'm glad to be able to fix
them in an era where relegation is gone
an experimentation isn't punished by the
system how nine showed that winning can
be more than all-star rosters and
superstar carries winning can also be a
seven-man of roster shuffling players in
and out to suit the opponent in the
draft in the situation at hand it can be
a long-suffering player who just needs
one more chance to redeem himself in the
new era of the LCS even the craziest
strategies can pay off and pile 9 Road
there's straight to work
better place thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]
you